no wait well it might be hard to do the
CGI and the biscotti but yeah I think we
could pull it off huh
no I wasn't listening to either of you
look who's in captain Holt's office who
that lady you are looking at the Second
Circuit Court of Appeals judge Laverne
Holt captain Holt's mom the creator
widowed at age 39
buttburn can't Abreu Holt
single-handedly raised two children and
still managed to become one of the first
black female federal judges what else
someone read her Wikipedia page no Jake
I wrote it oh okay the doors opening
we're gonna meet her everybody be cool
Santiago Oh what are you up to jammin
come on Joe
okay never mind Peralta come into my
office please sorry baby bullet he was
the Joe Mande yeah I think it was the
gym one thing detective Peralta this is
my mother the Honourable Laverne Holt
I'm very excited to meet you and let me
just say I'm a huge fan of your early
work I'm talking about this guy right
here
that was humor mother I know and I
thoroughly enjoyed it I love laughing
and laughter oh yes we all do but enough
chitchat
Peralta my mother's house was burgled
and you want me to cover the case
because I'm your favorite detective of
all time
yes also the jam on incident favorite so
why don't you tell us what happened when
I got home last night I noticed that the
window had been smashed the apartment
was a mess they took all of my jewelry I
assume they entered through the window
but I don't want to color your opinions
too late but no taken we'll stop by
later and check out the crime scene
that sounds appropriate well I should be
going detective captain your honor
detective captain your honor hey this is
fun let's do it again your honor
captain humor good day gentlemen okay
this is amazing spending time with your
mother and your childhood home ah the
adorable baby pictures the embarrassing
stories the founding fathers underoos
there will be no underoos like commando
that's enough okay this is a case I
expect you to act in a professional
manner not a personal one I know
sometimes it's difficult for you to
separate the two yeah you're referring
to the fact that I love making
everything pro first and all copyright
me yeah people love that around here
especially Amy if you know what I mean
wank finger gun perhaps Boyle is
deliberate no no no I'll be good I'll
leave I have recently taken a lover well
that's great congratulations who's the
lucky lady Pam's mom what Pam's mom
Colleen remember from your wedding
you're messing with me but what you did
not have sex with Pam's mom Oh big time
okay cars to drive she drives a green
camera and the seeds go all the way down
okay never tell Pam and then secondly
good a pact a pact although I may have
to break it tonight when Helene and I
tell Pam over dinner you all right oh my
god
hey Jim not now Toby my god get the hell
out of here idiot
and I said rules are no rules I just
have to kiss that beautiful face well
that's a note woman for you when we see
something adorable we attack it he is
adorable isn't he oh you chose well Ben
thank you admitted things are going
surprisingly well and pack it up it's
over we're screwed hey partes girlfriend
was this was the brains girlfriend Ben
Oh Ben your father brought his little
plaything
hi Benny hi Lonny thought you weren't
coming Lonny is my girlfriend and she's
important to me and I need her here Lou
Bonnie hi I'm Leslie what a wonderful
surprise we're so happy that you're here
what the hell Steve they didn't know I
was coming
no a spring break okay thanks everybody
for coming I'm so sorry you all have to
go home hey Red Vines anyone wear
Twizzlers family house is all clean the
wine is in the fridge what is this
picture of greywater I read an article
that said when you wash vegetables all
the nutrients leach into the water and
then you can drink it they call it a
super water
oh well that's neat I am gonna just hide
it right over here dad you almost ready
the santiago's are very punctual don't
call me bro I'm your son okay dude is
not an improvement the way they're here
oh now honey I know you're nervous but
it's gonna be fine we can handle
ourselves hola
Feliz Thanksgiving Jake told me you were
Cupid
yes I did and I regret it come on in so
nice to finally meet you I'm Victor and
I'm Camilla oh and you brought a turkey
she sure did
even though I told her that you were
making the turkey and all she need to
bring with Stephanie the stuffings
inside it and now we have two turkeys
just in case in case of one the most fun
why don't we just get comfortable my dad
is just yeah Care Bear which pants honey
there's Santiago's are here Feliz
Thanksgiving how was the trip in the
flight must have been on holidays we
press pause on that maybe you get some
pants fine put on some pants
oh wow
that is amazing I feel like a real
Puerto Rican Michael you're all set a
father telling you so change the
reservation to two people here and look
fun yeah Wow Botticelli's that sounds
like a special occasion yeah no it's
nobody I don't know I think Michael has
a date mm-hmm I think you have a day you
know I don't come on I think we should
just drop it
cuz obviously he doesn't want to talk
about it I don't deserve this guys yes
you know I don't just take the parrot
okay back to the old grind I was
probably gonna break up with her anyway
Oh doll it's too bad Pam it is very
complicated there are a lot of moving
parts he sounds complicated yeah but I
mean if you really like this person then
you should see where it goes you want me
to be happy of course part of the
problem is she's the mother of a close
friend of mine Oh more than a friend a
co-worker Oh
gossip who is it who is it who is it
Michael who it's okay
no no no oh my
that could have gone one of two ways but
I never expected her to get upset so how
did you two finally get together after
all these years
oh you know I've just been crazy about
her forever and then one day I picked up
my battered old guitar and I sang her a
song
oh how did it go you don't want to hear
it yes I do
well I don't have my guitar here sing
this song Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa
Rosa Rosa DSD SD SD SD SD SD SD s Rosa
Diaz Rosa dsds Rose are present yes yes
you are so cool
it's not better with a guitar okay just
put that away
who was that in the picture just my mom
kind of look like you're cold or gray me
take any of your friends it's not where
he has his arm around her and she was
showing off a ring wow you got a really
good look at that picture huh what's
going on Jake and Amy are engaged that's
okay what you understand love is
complicated why would you be okay with
that maybe though when you call his
dinner you were so nervous we were
worried you were jealous you were gay so
you would rather me be some dudes
mistress than being a loving
relationship with a woman well Jake and
I aren't dating
guess what your worst fears are real I'm
not straight I'm bisexual
and I don't care what you think about it
screw this I'm out of here I'm also
gonna go are you guys on venmo you know
figure out later this isn't the right
time
everybody pants now pants pants pants
pants pants she's had enough call it off
that's not how it works she's out wait
I'm stopping it
April no that stuff will melt the shell
off a garden snail I'm Porter eight I
can handle it okay this ends now
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you you're going back to hell
fine I got what I came for anyway I
found your underground safe I stole half
your gold
that's decoy gold you think I'd leave my
gold in a locked safe buried underground
where anyone could find it you don't
know me at all yes I do I knew you the
minute you were born I intend to be
there the minute you die
you